il ya quelques semaines vous présenter
le grand flagship de au pot pour l'année
2020 le hope au finepix de projet vous
emmener à boulogne billancourt josé tout
montrer je vous en reparler
prochainement pour l'instant l'heure est
venue de faire un gros focus sur le
deuxième modèle de cette gamme finepix
de series c'est le néo qui n'est pas un
smartphone milieu de gamme qui est un
smartphone haut de gamme puisque le
prochain smartphone très haut de gamme
il ya quelques jours on parlera du live
donc si vous n'êtes pas abonné abonnez
vous dès aujourd'hui pour tout savoir
au delà de vous parler de oppose donne
des astuces sur votre vie numérique je
vous parle des bourgs visage avec votre
approche des conseils des guides d'achat
plein de chocs smartphone monde
tablettes ordinateurs et compagnie donc
abonnez vous cliquez sur le petit bouton
qui situent juste laak sonner la cloche
comme ça vous serez tous mais pour
l'heure on va parler de ce modèle là duo
pop et indie kz2 neo qui est un
smartphone qui est extrêmement
intéressant qui fait plein plein plein
plein de belles promesses qui est très
cool et par plein de points différents
c'est une vidéo qui est réalisé en
partenariat avec au pot et boulanger ce
qu'on va faire aujourd'hui ce qu'on va
faire un point complet on va regarder de
smartphones sous tous les ans je vais
tout vous dire de l'écran de la
performance de l' usage multimédia de la
photo vous allez tout savoir sur
l'autonomie tout voilà tout tout tout
vous saurez tout sur le open x 2 neo et
je vous invite dès maintenant à me dire
si vous le trouvez intéressants s'ils
peuvent ou tenter directement en bas en
commentaire
oh
[Musique]
la première fois sur smartphone c'est
son poids son smartphone qui fait 171 g
ca smartphones qui est quand même très
léger c'est un smartphone qui est très
agréable à en termes de prise en main
qui est assez long mais voyons fait pour
très facilement avec un sa main en terme
de confort de tenues en main et bien ça
smartphones qui est adapté à tout un
chacun vous avez un verre un corning
gorilla glass 5 à l'avant mais également
à l'arrière qui va venir vous le protégé
alors pensé quand même à venir mettre
une coque de protection puisque même si
les protéger comme ça s'il tombe il ya
un moment vous savez il peut y aurait un
délai convenu pour trouver un capteur
d'empreintes digitales situé sous
l'écran qui les brouilles extrêmement
rapidement si vous le souhaitez vous
pouvez vous s'activer car reconnaissance
faciale et il est disponible dans deux
couleurs vous avez le bleu stellaire et
vous avez également le noir lunaire un
smartphone avec un écran grand cdu 6,5
pouces full hd + 2420 1080 pixels amoled
c'est un écran incurvé un des mois ça là
comme c'est tout mignon un écran qui
occupent 80 13,4 pour cent de la face
avant ratio vingt neuvième mais surtout
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'ici vous
avez un écran avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 heures ce qui va
vous apporter de la fluidité
lorsque vous allez venir naviguer sur
instagram scrollé sa porte vraiment en
termes de confort de visionnage et
notamment dans les grandes parties de
gaming et c'est très drôle parce que si
vous regardez le finepix de pros on a un
écran 120 hertz
là on a un écran 90 hertz et le modèle
light pour parra dans quelques jours
c'est un écran 60 hertz donc y en a pour
tout le monde un écran hd r10 plus
certifié lutter contre la lumière bleue
avec une gamme de couleurs sans qu'on
s'en dci p3c correspondra au mode vif
aux couleurs vives on pouvait aller
aussi aux couleurs douces le mode doux
ça sera du srgb pour moi les couleurs
vives iront très bien et une luminosité
maximale de 800 dit le gros point
positif des écrans amoled si vous n'êtes
pas coutume et cette technologie c'est
que ça vous permettra d'avoir des noirs
un fini puisqu'un pixels noirs est un
pixel et 1 et le fait que ce soit et un
va vous permettre d'économiser de la
batterie jusqu'à ce moment là le puits
que ça ne va pas venir consommer de
l'énergie
vous pouvez donc activer le dark mode
très facilement pour économiser beaucoup
d'énergie un écran de qualité pour usage
multimédia s'est super bien il vous
faudra rien aussi du son de qualité est
là ça marche quand même plutôt bien vous
avez deux haut parleurs haut parleurs
stéréo haut parleurs qui va se situer en
dessous du smartphone et un deuxième qui
va se situer en haut ça vous permet
d'avoir un peu plus d'immersion lorsque
vous allez me regarder du contenu
multimédia et jouer à des jeux
il ya également du dolby atmos et si
vous n'avez pas de prise jack
à la différence du light dont on parlera
pas de plus dans quelques jours mais
vous avez du bluetooth 5 points et vous
avez en plus de l'enregistrement audio
3d
si vous souhaitez faire vos propres
vidéos on a donc un combo écran aux jo
qui est complètement adapté à un usage
multimédia pour me regarder des séries
sur des flics semailles canal amazon
prague youtube que sais-je encore
d'ailleurs dit moi vous quel service de
vod vous utilisez en bas en commentaire
l'expérience da complètement maximiser
par le fait d'avoir du hdr 10 plus le
côté plus immersif avec le doubs
personnellement moi j'aime beaucoup
alors tout ça c'est vraiment bien mais
si on veut aller plus loin et notamment
en termes de gaming puisque c'est un des
gros usage aujourd'hui il vous faut se
tiennent derrière et si vous avez une
réponse tactile 180 m
mais vous avez surtout de la performance
avec le snapdragon 7 165 g couplé à 12
giga de ram
lp ddr 4x et 256 go de stockage ufs de
points qui nous donnent au score sur un
toutou 322000 161 points qui est aussi
très important avec le gaming c'est vous
avez un refroidissement liquide qui va
éviter que votre smartphone surchauffe
et c'est d'autant plus importante
puisque vous avez de la 5g éclat 5g va
venir chauffer alors vous avez de la 5g
si la 5g est disponible dans votre pays
et si vous avez souscrit et 9,5 g dont
vous n'avez pas de 5g vos smartphones
marchera très bien encadrés en 3g soyez
tranquille là dessus il faut savoir car
ça que j'ai fait chauffer davantage
qu'aux smartphones d'où l'importance
d'avoir un système de refroidissement
adapté un smartphone est également une
grosse batterie de 4025 milliampères
heures qui se recharge en usb c'est avec
de la charge rapide c'est un point très
important
c'est au pot ici on a de la vous que
quatre points à charger de 30 watts
fournissez la charge basse tension qui
vous leur chargera de 1 à 50 % en 20
minutes et de 1 à 100 % en 56 minutes
mais pour regarder une journée et demie
à deux jours selon vos usages selon ce
que vous allez en faire mais si vous
commencez à être un petit peu court
batterie vous branchez vous le recharger
en seulement un petit quart d'heure
vingt minutes vous êtes reparti pour une
journée très très facilement donc tout
ça très rassurant loes ses coloris os7
basé sur android disent ça marche bien
c'est clair c'est lisible
vous avez plein de paramètres pouvait
venir régler notamment en terme
d'affichage les notifications vous
pouvez cloner des applications phares ya
pas mal de possibilités et ça marche
très bien
un autre usage qui est extrêmement
important c'est toute la partie photo
ici vous avez pas moins de quatre
capteurs à l'arrière vous avez un
premier capteur de 48 mégapixels c'est
la sonic 500
86 ouvre à f en point cette qui est la
stabilisation optique mais également une
stabilisation électronique vous avez un
ultra grand angle de 8 mégapixels et
ouvre à f 2.2 avec un champ de vision de
115° une stabilisation électronique et
un mode macro vous pouvoir shooter à 3
cm un téléobjectif de 13 mégapixels
couvre f 2.4 avec de la stabilisation
électronique avec un zoom optique x de
zoom hybride x 5 et un zoom numérique x
20 on regarde le résultat des photos en
quelques instants et vous avez un
capteur monochrome de 2 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.4 vous avez un double flash
led
vous pouvez filmer en 4k jusqu'à 30
images par seconde et surtout ce qui est
aussi intéressant au delà de la photo
c'est la partie vidéo puisque ici vous
avez de la vidéo ultra stable alors la
vidéo ultra stable elle marche de deux
manières différentes vous allez pouvoir
avoir la vidéo ultra stable avec la
stabilisation électronique qui va se
faire sur le capteur principal sur le 48
mégapixels on va venir tromper dans
l'image
vous avez donc de la stabilisation
optique plus la stabilisation
électronique donc c'est extrêmement ce
talent et vous pouvez venir choisir un
deuxième mode pour avoir un champ de
vision un peu plus large ou là vous
allez de son ultra grand-angle avec de
la stabilisation électronique et l avant
vous avez une caméra de sel fille de 30
2 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.4 la partie
photo est vraiment intéressant mais si
je vous ai pris une photo à contre-jour
on voit bien qu'on a tous les détails du
ciel on voit bien l'oiseau qui est là
bon le soleil bien évidemment on voit
quand même bien des détails ici dans la
rue on passe sur l'ultra grand angle ça
fonctionne ça fait le taff zoom x 2
optique ça marche
x 5 hybride cette fois ci on se met dans
l'autre sens on est plus à contre jour
et là les couleurs je trouve vraiment
bien c'est juste c'est beau que ce soit
le siècle ce soir on a du détail de tous
les côtés ça marche très très bien
l'ultra grand temps que fait le taff
sera un peu moins précis mais une fois
de plus on est sur un ultra grand-angle
donc ça me paraît aussi normal on passe
sur le zoom optique x 2 le rendu
vraiment bien le foissac c'est un peu
moins terrible on le voit de suite on a
une dégradation de qualité mais ça
responsables sont à rechercher un peu un
peu plus loin et dès qu'on arrive sur le
zoom numérique x 20 je vous dis c'est
pas terrible du tout problèmes macro
plutôt bien on en reparlera plus loin
mais voilà même programmant je suis pas
trop fan et ici ça marche vraiment bien
le mode portrait et très cool marche
très bien on recommence avec des potes à
moi sur le capteur principal ça marche
l'ultra grand or une fois de plus son
père rapport précision mais ça
fonctionne pour me recruter un peu plus
large x 2 ça marche
x 5 ça ira bon fois 20 mois y est c'est
pas terrible du tout la caméra tarifs
aussi très bien le taf la colorimétrie
caméra principale ultra grand temps on
voit qu'on est différent de colorimétrie
si entre lui très longtemps les capteurs
principal x 2 ça fonctionnera fois ça
qu'on perd un petit peu une fois main on
oublie caméra principale
ultra-grand-angle x 2 x 5
ouais voilà fois vingt caméras principal
ultra-grand-angle regarder on a theme
bien le ciel on a les détails ça va c
permet plutôt bien x 2 c'est très cool x
5 un peu moins mais ça va il faut avant
on n'oublie caméra principale
ultra-grand-angle une fois de plus on
voit la différence de colorimétrie c'est
beaucoup plus saturé si vous voulez
regarder ici x 2 s'écoule fois cinq
moyens x 20 on oublie la regarder
lorsque je vais à chuter des fleurs ça
marche très très bien que je sois au
maquereau ou ne soit pas en accro le
rendu est hyper qualitatif là c'est la
macro regarder pour une fois j'apprécie
vraiment la macro c'est bien c'est juste
on a les détails on n'a pas
particulièrement beaucoup de bruit
regardez l'envoi la différence entre la
partie claire et la partie sombre là on
a l'impression qu'on perd un peu de
détails si je vais sur la photo d'un
côté et bien sûr récupère des détails
c'est très rigolo c'est comment ça
marche d'un point de vue logiciel
franchement j'ai rien à dire alors là on
va commencer la photo nuit là je vous ai
pris la photo telle qu'elle est avec le
capteur normale sans passer par le menu
et dès qu'on passe sur le mode nuit on
as assez bluffant alors il ya du
brouillard effectivement tout ça je suis
d'accord on est sur un mode nuit mais on
part de là quand même pied posé sur un
piège il explose de 45 secondes
ça marche très très bien et si je le
tiens à la main j'arrive à sortir sa
opère en plus en précision ça bouge
c'est pas terrible mais c'est quand même
vraiment bluffant un smartphone qui peut
accueillir une ado sim vous n'avez pas
la possibilité d'avoir une deuxième
carte sim vous n'avez pas la possibilité
d'étendre votre mémoire mais déjà avec
256 go de stockage vous avez vraiment de
quoi faire un smartphone qui donnait et
en résistant aux éclaboussures et à la
poussière
mais qui pourtant n'a aucune
certification il a dû annoncer à une
technique intéressante c'est les
antennes à 5g 360 seulement seule borne
alors qu'est ce que ça vous dit tout ça
ça vous dit que tout autour de votre
smartphone eh bien vous avez par moins
de dix antennes pour capter la 5g ou la
4g
ce qui veut dire que en fonction de la
pression de laquelle devait tenir votre
smartphone maroma en bas vous aller
bloquer le signal c'est par exemple vos
antennes étaient que situé vers le haut
si vous le tenez comme ça et bien vous
allez avoir une dégradation du signal
le fait que vous avez cette techno avec
des antennes de tous les côtés et bien
sûr les antennes du bar qui vont prendre
le relais
là les antennes bio qui vont prendre le
relais vous avez en permanence quatre
antennes de connecter et si vous avez un
das tête 2 0
825 watts par kilogramme tronc de 1,2
192 voix de par kilogramme et membre de
2,2 83 watts par kilogramme au combat
que le smartphone il touche les cases
que ce soit au niveau du multimédia avec
l'écran 90e pour hier visionner des
séries des films avec du hdr 10 plus
avec du son stéréo la qualité de la
dalle est vraiment bien maîtrisé l'audio
marche bien vous avez la puissance le
spectre est large sans forcément en
faire trop puisqu'il fait plus on reste
sur un smartphone donc on va pas non
plus lui demander la lune
il est très performant avec le stade
ragone 7 165 g vous allez pouvoir faire
tourner beaucoup de jeu du pl ace tort
il est aussi très bon en photo c'est un
smartphone complet et qui pourra séduire
beaucoup de monde personnellement j'aime
beaucoup les innovations de au pot c'est
souvent dans les petits détails qu'on
voyait techno intéressantes notamment le
fait d'avoir toutes ses antennes autour
on n'y pense pas forcément on en a parlé
on en reparlera et on reverra avec le
fatidique de pro d'ici quelques temps
c'est un smartphone qui est très cool
que je peux que vous recommander et qui
coûte la modique somme de 699 euros
s'il vous intéresse bien évidemment je
vous ai mis tous les liens en bas dans
la description a vous de me dire
maintenant comment vous trouvez est-ce
qu'il peut vous intéresser qu'est ce que
vous en pensez qu est ce que vous pensez
de la gale find x2 est ce que vous aimez
je vous invite bien évidemment rester
connecté parce que d'ici quelques jours
on se parle du light et vous allez voir
qu'il ya de live que le non sens aux
chambres attendra beaucoup d'amour
prenez soin de vous et à très très vite
[Musique]